- Ah! We're going burrito tasting!
- Woo!
(rock music)
(bangs)
- That's mine!
- [Nick] Ah!
- [Nick] Chorizo.
- [Diana] Eggs, cheese, mmm.
- [Nick] Homemade tortilla.
- [Diana] Dip it in the cheese.
- [Nick] Oh my goodness.
- Ah!
- [Nick] It's a little messy but all good.
(soft rock music)
- I'm dead.
- [Nick] (laughing) She's dead.
- This is unbelievable.
- I'm about to try the Trinity,
which is kind of basic.
I'm kind of basic.
Clean and delicious looking.
(soft rock music)
I need a moment.
Let me tell y'all something.
Actually I can't tell you
anything, because I'm speechless.
Literally deceased.
- Deceased. R.I.P.
- Cannot. R.I.P.
- I'm in a casket right now.
- R.I.P. us.
- Best breakfast burritos
- That.
- I've ever had.
- Oh my god, where are we going?
- Oaks Gourmet!
- Woo, gotta go, bye!
(rock music)
Oh my gosh you guys, we
have the Oaks bacon burrito,
and I'm about to show you the tea.
Look at that.
(rock music)
- [Diana] It's everywhere.
- Oh my goodness.
- I went for the vegetarian.
I love veggies and I
wanted to give it a try.
It's a ton of cheese and veggies.
This has scrambled eggs, let me show you.
- [Nick] Show us, boo boo.
- Oh my god.
- Look at that cheese.
(laughing)
- And I love that the
egg is scrambled because
I'm not a drippy egg type of gal.
I like my eggs scrambled.
It's so compact, like
everything just stays together.
I love that it doesn't taste vegetarian.
They're doing amazing things in there.
- Come to The Oaks, it's great.
See you at the next stop.
(soft music)
We just got three burritos.
- You're not ready.
- Wow.
- [Diana] So this is the
veggie, it has potato, tomato,
cheese, a lot of cheese.
I'm really excited about the potato.
Can we have some, like,
cool background music
playing on this?
(orchestral music)
- Here we go, hot link.
(soft beat music)
Wow.
I need another bite.
- So Nick wants me to try the hot links.
Apparently it's the best thing
he's ever put in his mouth.
(soft beat music)
It's hot, it's hot.
- That queso.
- It was so good, and I'm
definitely gonna go back.
I'm gonna take my mom, my
dad, my brother, my sister.
- Your auntie.
- No one's safe.
- Oaks Gourmet really made me feel good.
All the ingredients were
very, like, healthy I felt.
Cofax, my personal favorite.
There's a hot link burrito,
and it's (bleep) incredible.
- In a hot link.
For that one I'm gonna have
to say the bacon was the best.
For Oaks, the veggie, and
Homestate has to take the queso.
- That's it for this time.
- Until next time, don't
forget to subscribe.
(soft beat music)
- [Narrator] Oh yes!
(techno music)